you can't be anything if you don't know
who you are
especially if you want to be a singer if
you want to be a singer you have to sing
to people from deep inside here
and you know what's in there your heart
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
the invisible man's aldous hodge will
play hawkman in the upcoming dc
comics black adam film the character who
also goes by carter hall
is a warrior with giant bird-like wings
a bird-shaped helmet and a fierce
mace puckman was recently revealed
during the dc fandom event as one of
four superheroes who will appear in
black adam as part of the justice
society
along with atom smasher dark fate and
cyclone
and black adam himself aka the rock
confirmed the news on his
instagram writing hawkman is a critical
leading role for our movie
he's the fiery leader of the jsa justice
society of america
and one of the most beloved and
legendary characters in the dc universe
the film is scheduled to be released on
december 21st
2021 yara shahidi is set to play tinker
bell in disney's peter pan and wendy the
studio's latest
live action adaptation she will join joe
law who's set to play captain hook and
alexander maloney and ever anderson who
will play peter and
wendy though there have been many
adaptations of the peter pan story
shahidi will be the first black woman to
take on the role
the decision follows recent moves by
disney to diversify their cast selecting
halle bailey to star as ariel in the
little mermaid
and m night shyamalan just shared the
poster title and filming start of
old the directors shared the news on
twitter writing
feels like a miracle that i'm standing
here shooting the first shot of my new
film
it's called old and according to
collider the film is inspired by the
french graphic novel sand castle by
pierre oscar levy and artist frederick
peters
sandcastle follows a group of 13 people
who aren't able to leave
a mysterious secluded beach that hides a
dark secret involving time
which is referenced on the old poster
gail garcia bernal will star in the film
alongside phantom threads vicky creeps
loved craft countries abby lee
and hereditary's alex wolf
hispanic heritage month is underway and
we wanted to celebrate by deep diving
into some of our favorite spanish
language films
so today we're joined by film critic
writer and journalist monica castillo
who teamed up with rotten tomatoes to
curate a list of 110 essential spanish
language films
monica what are your top two
recommendations for
anyone from this list oh my goodness
there's so many good options
on that list so it was really hard for
me to just narrow it down to two but
off the top of my head i would have to
say lucrecia martell's la cienega
for anyone who hasn't seen an
argentinian film or
is familiar with martell's work it's a
really great introduction and it's
really interesting
kind of look at class in argentina
and then i would probably also point
them to gregory navas el norte
which was a really great movie kind of
about the journey from
i believe it's guatemala following the
good two indigenous siblings
on their way up to the united states and
that journey
going to the north are any of these near
and dear to your heart
probably gregory navas film is very dear
to me because um he's also a
marvelous filmmaker i'm a huge fan of
his work for those who aren't familiar
you might have seen
one of his other movies selena he also
did that one and a number of other great
movies me familia
and so many others so this is the first
one that really gave him his big break
you also worked with rotten tomatoes on
another list uh 13 barrier breaking
hispanic stars and do you have a
favorite film or character from that
list
that's also really tough because i love
so many of those actors
and actresses from the classic era but
my first would probably have to go
to rita moreno she was the one that i
really noticed when i was growing up
and i loved singing along with the song
of america from west side story
so like there's no one more iconic in my
mind
than rita moreno and that performance is
just wonderful
and i'm so glad that she did get the
chance to um be involved with the
new production of west side story that
you know oh
november yes nice that's great that's
awesome
so was there anything that you learned
while curating these lists that maybe
surprised you
that or just any interesting facts yeah
i really enjoyed digging more
into the careers of like dolores del rio
and i would love to watch more of lupe
velez's movies
if anything it's even just a list-making
activity for myself of just like movies
i need to track down
and and watch because you know these are
such great performances and
it's really worth looking for them uh
even if they're not always
easy to find out there on the streaming
sites all right cool well there you go
now you
everyone can go check out those lists
but where can they find you monica
i'm mostly on twitter at mcasty movies
that's mcas ti movies and i also have a
newsletter
and a patreon where you can find more of
my writing cool so there you go check
out monica on twitter thank you so much
for joining us
thank you for having me
available to watch in theaters on friday
spontaneous
caitlyn was cute airy hardly a reason to
pop like a zit
what happened caitlyn exploded what like
a bomb
no like a balloon what when students in
their high school
inexplicably start to explode seniors
mara and dylan struggle to survive in a
world where
every moment may be their last as an
unexpected romance blossoms between them
they soon discover that when tomorrow is
no longer promised they can finally
start living for today
the film stars catherine langford piper
periboo and charlie plummer
[Music]
and available to watch at home on friday
is
death of me
vacationing on an island off the coast
of thailand christine and neil oliver
awake hungover with no memory of the
previous night
they find footage on neil's camera and
watch horrified
as neil appears to murder christine with
24 hours until the next ferry and a
typhoon threatening the island
christine and neal attempt to
reconstruct the night's events and
are snared in a web of mystery black
magic and murder
alright well that's it for this week but
let us know if you'll be watching
spontaneous or
death of me i'm kale and i'll see you
next time
[Music]